I do a lot of work with the military and
I work with a lot of people who I would
consider great Patriots who are willing
to sacrifice for their Nations not
necessarily their lives but they
definitely make huge sacrifices they'll
never make huge money
um they are forced to uproot and move
their families on a regular basis they
travel and deploy and these are
sacrifices they're making for their
country they are great Patriots
unfortunately the word patriotism and
Patriot have been so politicized in our
modern day patriotism is a healthy thing
and regardless of what our politics are
I would hope that we all uh have a sense
of patriotism patriotism is simply
believing that our country is good and
striving to be better and even though we
are imperfect and do many things wrong
there is a striving and it is worth
sacrificing so that we can come become
the best version of ourselves
nationalism is believing our country is
better than every other country on the
planet